Kaname what's going on guys I mean
really you make some good games make
that soccer game it's almost as good as
the real good one you make that metal
gear solid game a pretty great bit
long-winded sometimes but they're pretty
awesome you got those pachinko machines
they're pretty fun okay you got those
got those gyms they got like a set of
gems as well I'm asking you to
peterbrown they got a set of Jim's this
a serious question yeah I got a set of
gym like Kaname like gyms we go and you
work out and everyone dresses up a solid
snake and leave me I'll messy and they
work at it's not right Peter Brant
expert on all things Konami I guess yeah
that's my official title now yeah yeah
did they get a bunch of health centers
they run a bunch of gambling stuff
around pachinko it's okay they're
they're backing out of video games in a
way that is sort of unprecedented right
so many companies fold and they put out
a press release like well we're done
fortunately people off the Japanese Way
is very different they tend to sort of
hot like mask decisions like that mask
the fact that maybe things aren't going
so well is this because the nature of
Japanese business being that like
corporations like this have their
fingers in many pies as opposed to the
Western tradition of a business very
much being like in one sort of vertical
like Kaname is a very got a widespread
portfolios just kind of their unique but
I think you look at someone like Sony
then you can say they're not totally
unique in that regard yeah but I think
it has more to do with the the culture
in Japan things are handled differently
sure so do you think this is Konami
basically stepping away from games in a
sort of intentional but just maybe
slightly protracted way before we say
that can we just list the evidence real
quick yeah boy what why we are you
thinking Kaname is getting out of games
in a way yeah so somebody that spoke to
me on record but anonymously you know he
basically laid down the groundwork for
everything that is sort of come out now
we are Kaname is push regime aside he's
no longer an executive content officer
he's no longer even an official employee
he is a contractor and
along with other heads of the studio
from Kojima Productions which is now
Konami Tokyo yeah could you approach his
name is off the record there could you
productions LA which opened about a year
and a half ago is now Konami Los Angeles
rhythm no more Fox with lightning legs
yeah right now retinol pulled off the
graphic and everything that's how
everything started right they were
removing all these this text and you
know I do could you McCain was gone he's
one of the few developers out there
whose name is credited on bosses yeah
you know I mean so of course people are
going to notice when that happens and
big and asked a lot of questions and
economies response to all these rumors
that we reported on was hey no he's
still working on the game and also we're
making a new metal gear and we're hiring
right now basically skirting around the
issue without denying it without
confirming it and placating fans who may
think oh no we're not going to get more
metal gear yeah but what Kaname is
missing when they say that for that end
assuming that's their goal is that
people don't just want a new metal gear
they want a new metal gear game from
hideo kojima because metal gear is Hideo
Kojima and and so that's a big problem
and you know people were excited for
silent Hills because hey we love metal
gear but we've you know it's kind of
been the same story being told in
different chunks over the course of a
few decades and Silent Hill was a chance
for him to do something really really
new he brought in blood like Guillermo
del Toro obviously who was very exciting
especially in that realm of horror and
the sort of dark fantasy and Konami to
pull the plug on that it's not
surprising given what i was told that
kojima yes he is a contractor but he's
also pissed and he's yeah you know he
wants to do right by probably his name
and also for the fans to finish metal
gear but work on work on silent Hills
hadn't actually begun it was still in
the planning on paper phases after PT
they were just heads down on phantom
pain still are yeah and so yeah so you
know that's been cancelled and the guy
that I spoke with he you know and asked
him at sandhills initially his answer
was well that's between del Toro and
Konami so that's what I assumed was the
deal yeah but del Toro at this event
this film event this weekend said that
he's really sad he doesn't get to work
on this game I don't know if that's
because he only would have done it with
Kojima I bet that's part it sounds like
that that was the sort of the exciting
part of that relationship but what that
was
that was the impetus for the entire
project the hook that's the exciting
part of the relationship even if
Kojima's leaving konami I mean this is a
new opportunity for him and presumably
all his co-workers who are also getting
shuttle out the door yeah to do
something new it might not sit have
metal gear solid in her name but you
still have that creativity behind it
yeah and there's so there are two
discussions here right there's the point
you bring up where it's like this frees
up Kojima to do something new and
exciting which I'm personally very
interested in yeah I think absolutely
anyone who appreciates the work he's
done should look forward to that because
he's not limited to just one series you
know from everything every evidence
we've seen over the years even that
series has changed a lot and he's done
really interesting things with it so we
have every reason to hope and believe
that he'll be able to do something
creative and very interesting and unique
moving forward on the other hand you
have a company like Kaname who's been
around for a very long time is
responsible for publishing so many great
video games series but since the dawn of
the HD era it's just been on a CD clone
sleeve the whole time and and i just
realized today which was a surprise to
me but winning 11 pro evo makes more
money than metal gear no I really Millie
your solid has been on a decline well if
that even comes out this year yeah sad
times for Konami maybe something will
see from cause I'm on the future fingers
crossed peter brian thank you so much
for coming on